I've chosen the West house from bid ndon
in Kent how are you gonna see - right
where is it beeping we're in the kitchen
I met grain 15 years ago when he worked
next door to my first London restaurant
even then he showed real flair theories
to issues around the central ingredient
and you know not funny around with it
too much Chuck too many other things on
the plate and trying to enhance you know
bring out the flavors
Graham hasn't always been a chef he
started out as a drummer for 80s hair
rockers Yaya no I've never heard of them
either
he still has some of the hair but
happily not the shorts
luckily I've done that for long so on
various tours and albums and also got to
see the world
just 17 years ago
Grenn gave up rock and roll to follow
his dream of becoming a chef working in
the string of top London restaurants
then eight years ago he took a huge risk
he moved his family to the Kent
countryside and opened up the west house
eighteen months after opening he won his
first wish to stop that's not bad for a
drummer and when you won the mission
style were you're on your own the
kitchen Wow he's a one-man band back to
play the drums again everything about
this family Russian is understated old
English charm grands partner Jacky works
front of house with their children Jake
and Jess who's in charge
happy been in charge beginning I didn't
know what I was doing and now eight
years on it's not as bad as it was but I
didn't like it first no I'll start off
with the ham and eggs it's very very
clean really nice flavors pop it on the
menu yeah yeah very I can imagine why
what I like most about West House is the
fact that Graham is a is a true chef he
cooks from the heart ninety frills he's
into flavor and it shows
this quaint English restaurant is about
to be severely tested because my diners
will soon be arriving and ordering all
at the same time basically I'm just
expecting the whole family to put in an
amazing performance today to pull this
one off
just like the milestone they have just
two hours to serve everyone
this little 11:00 table restaurant is
gonna be packed you have a mission star
so myself and my diners are expecting
experience there as soon as you can get
the first table you see you both ready
to order
that looks like a traffic controller
tickets are confusing but a food coming
out of the kitchen is simply perfect
starters include warm smoked haddock
Apache Oh with bacon dressing and pee
shoes and that delicious ham hop with
scotch egg and black pudding Gridley
knock you as well as the first one for
me I've never seen that before
just to color off then it gets tossed
through with the artichokes for mains
there's a choice of roast chicken with
herb gnocchi grill with samphire or lamb
with sweetbreads
why would you stop and order there like
that I'm finding the ordering system
impossible to fathom
and Jackie's handwriting is more like a
doctor's than a Maitre D' no one can
read it I really wrote the ticket out
and then pick that up as well and you
already sent it was my fault I left it
on there because it was a bit couldn't
understand my writing so so that was the
[ __ ] day to do it okay
table setting - chicken